طب رابطه الشمال مرتبط منذ فتره طويله
بحزب روسيا الموحده حزب بوتن ومرتبطين
بشراكه رسميه كيف ترون هذا في ضوء عضويه
ايطاليا المهمه للاتحاد الاوروبي من جهه
وحاله الحرب بين اوروبا وروسيا متمثله في
اوكرانيا من جهه الثانيه الى اي مدى يمكن
لحزبكم ان يكون منطلق مفاوضات بين روسيا
واوكرانيا
تجاه الديمقراطيه الغربيه اوكرانيا وبناء
على ذلك اخذت القوه السياسيه التي ينتمي
اليها موقفا واضحا وعارضا للخيار الروسي
وقررت الدعم الكامله للديمقراطيه الغربيه
حالف مع الناس وانا اقول بيودوه ان ربط
الرابط اليوم مع روسيا الموحده وسياسات
التي انتهجتها موسكو في اوكرانيا هو خطا
كبير لاننا نتخذنا بوضوح المسافات كرد على
التغيير السلبي في سياسه روسيا الى غايه
سنوات
مفيدا محاوله جلب روسيا الى تحالف مع
بلدنا اوروبا لكن للاسف روسيا تجاهل
التوقعاتنا وانتظاراتنا ولذلك كان علينا
اخذ موقف النور
خلال الانتخابات وبعدها هل ايطاليا حقا
قادره ماليا وسياسيا على تحمل تكلفه تغيير
مسارها المؤيد للاتحاد الاوروبي ونيته
المساله ليست متعلقه ببساطه بفرص اقتصاديه
وانما هي دفاع عن الديمقراطيه وعن مبادئنا
المرتبطه باوروبا
واكرر انه لدينا موقف واضح جدا وبالتالي
نحن نضع في المرتبه الثانيه المشاكل
الاقتصاديه والصعوبات الاقتصاديه المشكله
هي الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه التي نرغب بشده
في دفعها الى الامام هذه اولوياتنا ولا
يوجد شك في ان مهاجمه روسيا لاوكرانيا جلب
مشاكل اقتصاديه لكل اوروبا ولذلك على
اوروبا التجاوبك جسم موحد لتقديم اجوبه
لمؤسساتها ولشعوبها وهذا بالتاكيد بحاجه
الى الاداء والقياد مبدا والديمقراطيه
التي تميز قارتنا والتي لا تلتقي مع خيا
بلدا قرر غزوه بلد اخر حر مثل اوكرانيا